maintenant
irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
cameroun bam la ville une population de
25 mille habitants les bamoun originaire
de mésopotamie vainqueur des bantous de
religion président à leur destinée
islamisme et protestantisme scènes de
rue scènes de marché est celle de
coiffeur car là bas les cheveux aussi 20
francs pour l'avoir filmé
puisque nous en étions à la tête
commençons par l'esprit celui des dames
où mme est dans un musée que nous
visiterons pas faute de temps ces trois
actrices télé devront donc tueur hélène
retrace des scènes de l'histoire
nationale
lacam joue là bas un rôle important on
retrouve dans les sculptures qui
l'ornent des animaux totems lyon les
arts a régné bruno vomir ce faux ce
faire on soumet le bambou au feu de
certaines herbes qui font disparaître la
couleur verte
2 les corses et noircissent les dessins
qui apparaissent en relief ces
coquillages sont des cauris
ces termes de simples perles et l'un
comme l'autre servent à cet usage
la calebasse à vin de palme est parfaite
pour le whisky et le pastis long travail
de patience
et voilà le résultat
quant à elles concordent à lui son
origine est millénaire et sa
signification en mesh construire est un
peu chère à l'homme
ici mon 6.10 de cette manière les
briques sont de terre séchée
elles sont soudés les une jauge autres
au moyen de terre fraîches
je ne peux être plus un essai maison
résisteront pendant de longues années
aux averses torrentielles de la saison
des plus elles résisteront malgré ce
toit qu'une qui nous paraît ô combien
fragile et qui en réalité vaut mieux que
nos brut parfois si mal juin
c'est le cadre du plafond fabrique sur
le sol c'est plus commode ou moins
fatiguant l'armature est fixé au moyen
de cheville vous l'avez vu puis
quadrillé de branche est unie par des
ligatures les éléments de pop de pente
qui supporte le revêtement de chaume
son travail est aussi sur le sol et
réunis entre eux par une fibre végétale
on fixe le chaume et le tout est hissé
est solidement attachés sur le toit
on décore les façades et on habite
c'est simple comme mode et confortable
autre construction par un procédé très
différents en voyez vous même sous les
ordres du révérend je jouais mon niche
qui donne essor à un nouveau
protestantisme africain s'élève ce
temple cette nouvelle religion a pour
base une fois également sincère mais
d'une très grande tolérance quant à la
vie privée de chaque fidèle
bien sûr tout se fait dans la joie ou
son du tam-tam de la musique
le tam tam remplacent les cloches le
jour de l'inauguration la foule vient de
partout selon ses mots les plaquettes
chacun amène son siège c'est plus
prudent on est sûr d'en trouver un
est ce qu'ils ne parviendront pas à
entrer prendront place dehors d'où ils
entendront et les roues si bien grâce au
mur à quai en bois
le sacristain lui est vêtu le velours ou
plusieurs mariages ont été célébrés
maillage fixé pour la postérité grâce à
la pellicule de louis ninja alba limete
assisté de son bled qui lui a tenu le
parapet
et puisqu'il y a deux religions il ya là
bas deux façons de se marier
voici la seconde c'est un mariage
musulman schismatique célébré par un
imam qui lui aussi est en rébellion
contre l'autorité religieuse officielle
les présents et le lit de la jeune
mariée sont exposés et comme le veut le
coran elle habitera seule une petite
maison derrière celle de son époux
tous
voilà qui éloignera les mauvais esprits
inutile de préciser que ces coutumes
remonte au temps payet on se livre à la
joie on danse crie on chante un mariage
ou une cérémonie gay recouverte d'un
drap blanc ce qui la protège d'une
mahler la mariée portait sur un cheval à
son domicile une feinte qu'elle
n'étouffe où les ventes
et tout ce livre joyeusement à la fête
cet acteur naples et pineau et à
vendredi saint en rentrant de la prière
le sultan a accepté que pour vous soit
filmé les scènes qui vont suivre
généralement célébrées dans l'ombre de
la grande salle du palais
danse guerrière vestiges des temps
chevaleresque et le sultan contemple le
spectacle qui lui est offert l'homme
oiseau est là et soul à la ruée des
guerriers s'élancent à l'assaut des
muses imaginaire les ennemis hier
ça
je
c'est elle le prologue voici le jeu
dramatique et funèbre
comme jadis à la veille des combats
contre les balles y mettez du sud et les
fulbé du nord on va exécuter à
prisonniers capturés lors d'une bataille
précédent on enchaîne
et le roi des capitules
lamentation
lorsqu'elle fut
comment voit en souvenir du soi-disant
défunt
deffins noyer se porte fort bien et tout
s'achève par des rires et des chansons
ap
lyman chagnaud vous a proposé voyage
sans passeport cette émission a été
réalisée avec le concours d'un film
francis de norville et celui de solange
péters montage claude richard sont
annick bdi hans-peter montage claude
richard sont annick v10 illustration
sonore denise glaser